สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะ
ขอต้อนรับนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะสู่ห้องเรียน
คนิ Thai ห้องเรียนฟังภาษาไทยให้ง่ายๆค่ะ
นะวันนี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กกับครูชิมาพบกับนัก
เรียนทุกคนนะคะในวันอะไรคะครูชิวันนี้วัน
ศุกร์ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 16 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะ
กุมภาพันธ์อืปีพ.ศเท่าไหร่คะ
2567 ปีค.ศเท่าไหร่คะ
2024 ค่ะค่ะวันนี้ครูปุ๊กูชิมาพบกับทุก
คนในวันศุกร์นะวันที่ 16 เดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพุทธศักราช 2
2567 ปีคริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะนะค่ะวันนี้ครูชิไม่อยากอยู่
บ้าน
เบื่อไปดูหนังมเอ้าไปดูหนังหรอหนังอะไรคะ
ครูชิครูปุ๊กชอบดูหนังอะไรล่ะครูปุ๊กอ่ะ
ชอบดูหนังการ์ตูนนะกตูนอืใช่แล้วก็ชอบดู
หนังแบบแนวแบบอื
หนังการ์ตูนเนี่ยการ์ตูนแบบดนนี่เหรอใช่น
ชอบค่ะเพราะว่าจะมีเพลงด้วยลลล
ลลาอะไรอย่างเงี้ย
อืมนะก็ครูก็ชอบเหมือนกันแล้วก็แบบนะ
การ์ตูนก็สนุกวาดรูปสวยใช่มยวดิสนีย์
เนี่ยนะแล้วก็บางทีเาก็เปลี่ยนเป็นใช้คน
มาเล่นไงนะอือก็นะตอน Beauty  and  the
Beast นะครูุก็ดูไปดูที่โรงหนังด้วย
อ่าเพราะว่าบอสดิสนีย์เ้าให้เอาคนมา Make
Up นะเป็นนะเป็น
อสูรอืเจ้าชายอสูรค่ะเโฉมงามเจ้าชายอสูร
นะชอบดูหนังประเภทประเภทที่เป็นแบบ
การ์ตูนหรือออกมาจากการ์ตูนแล้วก็มาสร้าง
เป็นหนังอ่าอืนะหรือหนังแนววิทยาศาสตร์
ค่ะนะ
โอหอย่างอะไร Back  To  The  Future อ่า
ได้ค่ะนะ
อืหรือเป็นหนังเกี่ยวกับอะไรนะเอ่อ Lucky
หรือ the  time เกี่ยวกับเวลาเห็นมยที่มี
เวลาแล้วก็โอ้โหเวลาจะหมดแล้วอย่างเงี้ย
อืก็ครุณูก็ชอบแนวแบบ
แฟนตาซี
ออทุกก็จริงๆดูได้
เลย
เหมือนครูปุ๊กเนี่ยชอบดูหนังทุกประเภทเลย
ดูได้หมดใช่หนังตลกเนี่ยก็ดีค่ะเพราะว่า
เวลาดูแล้วก็หัวเราะสนุกค่ะนะมิสเตอรบีน
อย่างเงี้ยนะเป็นหนังตลกนะนก็ชอบเหมือน
กันนะก็จริงๆแล้วก็ชอบหลายๆอย่างนะหลายๆ
แนว
ออส่วนูชิเนี่ยคูชิชอบหนังแบบประเภทหนัง
แอคชั่น
อ๋อเมื่อก่อนเราจะเรียกหนังบู๊ค่ะบู๊อ
นะหนังบู๊หนังแอคชั่นอืออ๋อออที่มีการต่อ
สู้กันโอเมื่อก่อนก็มีทั้งหนังจีนนะคะที่
มีเฉินหลงเล่นใช่มยอหรืออะไรเกิดทันหรือ
เปล่าไม่รู้นะนักเรียนหลายคนอาจจะเกิดไม่
ทันบูทลี
โูชิชอบมากตั้งแต่เด็กๆเอคาเต้อืออก็คือ
เป็นหนังต่อสู้เนาะนะแล้วยิ่งแบบโอ้โห
เมื่อสมัยก่อนตอนครูปุ๊กเด็กๆครูชิเด็กๆ
เนี่ยจะมีหนังจากประเทศจีนมาเยอะๆนะแล้ว
ก็เป็นแบบวัดเศร้าหลินอะไรอย่างงี้ใช่
มั้ยต่อสู้นะนะ
โอ้โหกระโดดจากหลังคาลงมาอย่างเงี้ยเนอะ
อื้อหือสนุกหรือบางทีครูชิก็ชอบหนัง
ประเภทแบบฆาตกรรมอ่ะหนังอาชญกรรม
อาชญกรรมเกี่ยวกับการฆ่าเหมือนๆกับเราไม่
รู้นะว่าใครเป็นคนฆ่าอ๋ออย่างงั้นูชิต้อง
ชอบชลคมโอเป็นนักสืบใช่มั้ยไม่รู้ว่าใคร
เป็นคนฆ่านะเพราะว่ามีคนตายใช่มั้ยพอมีคน
ตายแล้วเนี่ยตำรวจเนี่ยก็ต้องหาค่ะใครฆ่า
ตายได้ยังไงใช่มยนะก็จะมีนักสืบเหมือนๆ
ชลอโฮมแล้วก็แดมทดมทะแดมทะแดมทดม
ทดมนะหานะว่ามีอะไรนะฆ่าด้วยอะไรนะหรือ
ว่าปืนใช่มยยิงด้วยปืนแล้วปืนเนี่ยอยู่
ที่ไหน
อ่าเห็นมยอันเนี้ยอันนี้คูณิก็ชอบนะดู
หนังสไตล์แบบฆาตกรรมนะคะอย่างมันก็จะมี
ทั้งหนังจีนหนังฝรั่งเหมือนกันนะที่เป็น
แบบโอ
อาชญากรระห่ำระห่ำแบบเหมือนกับคนบ้าชอบ
ฆ่าคนน่ะเออเนี่ยเวลาดูแล้วแบบมันน่า
สงสัยไงอหรือว่าแบบฮอลลิวูดอาจจะทำแบบ
ฆาตกรต่อเนื่องอืต่อเนื่องหมายถึงว่าผู้
ชาย 1 คนเนี่ยสมมุตินะเป็นผู้ชายเป็นคน
ชอบฆ่าใช่มั้ยอาจจะมีความโกรธแค้นไม่ชอบ
ผู้หญิงที่มีผมบอลนะผมบอลใช่มั้ยแล้วก็
เลยแบบเวลาเค้าเนี่ยก็จะเจอผู้หญิงอาจจะ
ที่
บาเห็นผู้หญิงผมบอลน่ะเขาก็จะไปคุยแล้วก็
พูดคุยเสร็จแล้วก็หลอกไปแล้วก็ไปฆ่านะ
แล้วก็ตำรวจก็ไม่รู้ใครฆ่าแล้วเดี๋ยวก็มี
คนตายที่นู่นที่นี่ที่นั่นนะเป็นผู้หญิง
ผมบอลผู้หญิงผมบอลผู้หญิงผมบอลอย่างเงี้ย
นะตำรวจก็เอ๊ลักษณะวิธีการฆ่าเนี่ยเหมือน
กันทุกคนเลยนะตำวันเนี้ยูชิก็ชอบอ๋อเออ
ไม่น่ากลัวเหรอคะูชิก็บางบางเรื่องก็น่า
กลัวนะอย่างเล stocker  Killer อย่าง
เงี้ยโอ้โหแบบ
โอ้โหดูดูดูแล้วเนี่ยไม่กล้าจะใช้
โทรศัพท์
เลยไม่แล้วครูชี้อ่ะคือฮอลลีวูดฟิลมเนี่ย
ชอบทำอันนี้ค่ะครูปุ๊งเนี่ยมากๆเลยเค
เรียกว่าหลอนค่ะหลอนหมายถึงว่าเวลาเราไป
พักที่ไหนเรากลัวมากเพราะว่าหนังฆาตกรรม
แบบเนี้ยนะส่วนมากจะเกิดที่ห้องน้ำนึกออก
มั้เวลา้าที่ห้องน้ำเลยหญิงอาบน้ำเปิดฝัก
วัวมีน้ำๆๆใช่มยแล้วก็มีสบู่จุ๊ดๆอ่าถู
สบู่แล้วก็นะเสร็จแล้วก็จะมีคนเนี่ยถือ
มีดแต่ไม่เห็นหน้านะไม่มีหน้าแล้วก็มีด
แล้วก็เดิน
มาเสร็จแล้วเราก็ต้องมีดนตรีที่มันตื
เตแล้วเราก็จะแบบลุ้นเฮ้ยเฮ้ยผู้หญิงล็อค
ห้องน้ำหรือเปล่าเขาจะเข้ามาฆ่าได้มผู้
หญิงก็ลัล
ลาเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยก็มีนะฆาตกร
เหแล้วก็มีเลือดค่ะกระจายที่
พลาสติกใช่มยเวลาแล้วก็มีเลือดแค่นั้น
แหละเราก็รู้แล้วออเกิดเหตุฆาตกรรมแเนี้ย
เลือดเห็นมยจะเป็นแบบนี้ก็อันนี้ครูชิก็
ชอบดูนะมันมีความรู้สึกตื่นเต้นลุ้นเอ้ย
ใครเป็นคนฆ่าเขาจะตายมั้ยเออแล้วแล้วครู
ชิคิดว่าเวลาเราไปนอนโรงแรมต่างจังหวัด
เนาะเราไปต่างจังหวัดเราต้องนอนโรงแรม
เวลาไปโรงแรมอาบน้ำที่โรงแรม
เนี่ยเราจะคิดถึงหนาใช่มย
ใช่
แต่หนังที่ครูปุ๊กชอบครูชิก็ชอบนะสไตล์
แบบวิทยาศาสตร์เ่ะสไตล์วิทยาศาสตร์อันนี้
ูชิก็ชอบเหมือนกันนะเหมือนๆกับอะไร
อ่ะอตอเหรอเป็นหนังที่แบบเหมือนกับอนาคต
น่ะไม่รู้จะเกิดอะไรกับกับโลกใบนี้ออนะ
หรือมีมนุษย์ต่างดาว
มานักเรียนจะเกิดทันมั้ยคะ
ET นักเรียนบอก
เอาแต่ Star  Wars ก็
พออวตารได้มยอวตารก็ได้ค่ะอวตารภูชีก็ชอบ
นะอืนะก็สวยดีนะก็สร้างภาพได้สวยนะอวตาร
นะหรือหนังแบบสไตล์แบบแฟนตาซีไปเลยอ่ะที่
แบบมีอะไรนะมีมีผู้วิเศษ 4 คนอีกคนเนี่ย
ยืดตัวได้อ๋อก็เป็นหนังแบบเอ่อของญี่ปุ่น
การ์ตูนญี่ปุ่นใช่มั้ยนะเหมือนๆกับเอ่อ
อะไรที่มันเหลือเชื่อ
นะเราก็รู้สึกแบบว่าเออหนังประเภทนี้ก็ก็
สนุกนะดูแล้วก็สนุกนะคะเป็นหนังเกี่ยวกับ
เอ่อเรื่องคือเวลาที่เาทำแล้วทำให้เรารู้
สึกมันมันสนุกไปด้วยเหมือนๆกับพวกอะไรอ่ะ
เอ่อมี
มี 4  4 พลังกายสิทธิ์อ่ะครูปุ๊กรู้จัก
มั้ยคนนึงที่เป็นแบบตัวใหญ่ๆใช่มั้ยอีกคน
ก็อาจจะเป็นเอ่อ
อเมริกันใช่มยเป็นเป็น 4 พลังอ่ะคนนึงที่
เวลาโกรธแล้วตัวจะใหญ่แบบพนักเขียวพักอื
หรือหรือแบบอะไรอ่ะ
เอ่อแฟนตัสติโใช่มั้ยที่มันมีมันมนุษย์
ที่แบบเป็นไฟได้มนุษย์ที่เร็วอะไรแบบ
เนี้ยมันมีความรู้สึกว่าแบบเนี้ยหนัง
สไตล์วิทยาศาสตร์แบบเนี้ยมันมันก็ดูสนุก
ดีนะหรือเป็นพวกจอมเวทมนตร์อะไรจอมเวท
มนต์มีเวทมนตร์แล้วก็มันก็เป็นพ่อมดเสกนะ
คไม่ไม่ใช่ชักชักกี้
ไอ้ตุ๊กตาผีอันนั้นจากหมอผีน่ากลัวว่าอัน
นั้นเป็นหนังอันนั้นจะเป็นหนังแบบเอ่อ
เป็นเป็นหนังสยองขวัญสยขวใช่มั้ยดูแล้ว
รู้สึกแบบอีสยองขวัญหนังที่แบบน่ากลัวใช่
ๆใช่นะชักกี้เนาะหน้าตาตุ๊กตาตุ๊กตาเนี่ย
มันน่ารักนะแต่มันทำไมแบบตอนที่มันน่า
เกลียดมันน่าเกลียดมากเลยน่ากลัวใช่มั้
ตุ๊กตาเนี่ยมันโอน่ารักแต่ทำไมชักกี้นี่
อื้อหือคือตาเวลาเห็นตาเ้าอ่ะอืออ๋อเวลา
ตามสมันน่ากลัวค่ะอ่า
นะน่ากลัวแล้วก็แบบตามค่านะเออแล้วหนัง
มันมีกี่ประเภทเนี่ยครูปุ๊กอย่างที่เรา
ชอบเนี่ยก็ก็สไตล์คล้ายๆกันเนอือนะหนังผี
ค่ะอ้าอ่าหนังผีหรือบางทีเราเรียกหนัง
สยองขวัญก็หนังระทึกขวัญก็ได้นะดูแล้วแบบ
ตื่นเต้นต้องคุมหัวแล้ว
อืสุก 13
โนะฝรั่งกลัวเลข 13 ใช่มยนะวันศุกร์ด้วย
โอศุกร์ 13 โอน่ากลัวค่ะ
นะชื่ออะไรนะไอ้ตัวที่ออกมาเนี่ยไศุก 13
เนี่ยนะขึ้นมาจากหลุมใช่มั้ยใช่น่ากลัว
ค่ะนักเรียนเาเรียกว่าสยองขวัญนะทำให้เรา
อ่ะรู้สึกแบบนอนไม่หลับค่ะ
เออเห็นมยหรืออะไรอ่ะ
ลูซี่นะเป็นเป็นผู้หญิงไงเป็นผู้หญิงที่
แบบไปไปเป็นนักท่ามยออแบบเนี้ยเออนะ
อันเนี้ยเป็นหนังที่น่ากลัวใช่มั้ยหนัง
สยองขวัญหนังระทึกขวัญหรือบางทีก็เป็น
หนังผีนะอแต่เาบอกว่าหนังผีไทยน่ากลัวค่ะ
ดู
ซิเรามีผีเยอะค่ะ
นะแล้วประเภทแบบหนังผจญภัย่ะค่ะคออผจญภัย
ครูปุ๊กก็ชอบค่ะ
นะอย่าง Private  of  the คียนได้มยเออ
กัปตันแจ็คสร่นะฮผจญภัยไปหาสมบัติค่ะมี
กล่องสมบัติอืนะแจ็ค SP อันนี้ก็เป็นแบบ
หนังผจญภัยนะเราไม่รู้ว่าเต้องไปเจอกับ
อะไรใช่นะนะหรือมัมมี่นะเพราะว่าคนเนี่ย
อยากไปเอาสมบัติไปเอาเงินเอาทองแล้วก็ไม่
รู้ว่าอยู่ที่ไหนแล้วก็พอหาได้ก็จะต้องไป
นะไปที่ขุมทรัพย์แล้วก็ไม่รู้ต้องเจอกับ
ปัญหาอะไรเนาะนะอยู่ๆก็มีแบบโอ้โหฟาโลลุก
ขึ้นมา
แบบเป็นมัมมี่เลยนะเรื่มอมมี่ก็มีหลายภาค
นะอือือใช่ค่ะอันนี้ก็เป็นหนังเป็นเป็น
หนังเกี่ยวกับการผจญภัยนะคะไม่รู้ว่าจะ
เกิดอะไรขึ้นเหมือนกันใช่อันนี้ก็ตื่น
เต้นดีค่ะครูก็ชอบเหมือนกันเพราะดูแล้ว
มันจะไม่สยองขวัญเท่ากับไอ้หนังพวกแบบฆ่า
พวกอะไรแบบนหนังผีอะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยเราก็รู้จักหนังบู๊หรือหนังแอคชั่น
หนังผจญภัยนะคะหนังตลก่ะคะหนังตลกมิสเตอ
บีนไงหนังอ่าอ่านะเอออันนี้ก็ดูแล้วผ่อน
คลายดีนะใช่
นหรือใครที่ปากกว้างๆนะค่ะ The  mas
ค่ะอันนี้หนังตลกอย่างอย่าอย่างหนัง Bad
บอยนี่เป็นหนังตลกมั้ยมันมันก็เป็นบู๊บู
แบบตลกๆอ่ะออือื
นะก็อันนี้เนี่ยก็ก็ชอบดูเหมือนกันนะดู
แล้วมันก็คายเครียดดูสนุก
นะเหมือนเราทำงานมาเหนื่อยๆเนาะก็อยากดู
แบบอะไรที่มันตลกๆสนุกสนุเปลี่ยน
อารมณ์ให้รู้สึกอารมณ์ดีนะบางทีหัวเราะไป
คือหนังไทยเนี่ยจะมีสร้างเป็นหนังตลกอ
เยอะใช่มั้ยหนังตลกที่แบบว่าดูแล้วแบบเรา
ก็ต้องแบบหัวเราะไปด้วยใช่เอ้าเค้าบอกคน
ไทยเนี่ยอารมณ์ขันเยอะหรือว่าอารมณ์ดี
อารมณ์แบบสนุกเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยก็มีนะมีคน
ที่เป็นคนจีนน่ะมาให้คนไทยเนี่ยเขียนพอต
เรื่องนะเรื่องหนังนะแล้วก็ทำรายได้เนี่ย
ให้กับคนจีนมากๆนะนะแล้วก็มีคนจีนมา
เที่ยวประเทศไทยเยอะเพราะว่ามาตามรอยหนัง
นะตามรอยซีรีส์ตามรอยหนังนะรานั้น
ก็อย่างอย่าหนังตลกที่ครูชีชอบอีกเรื่อง
นึงก็โฮมโลนไงโฮมโลนมีตั้งหลายภาคก็จะรู้
สึกว่าเด็กเก่งนะแล้วก็เวลาเห็นขโมยเอ๊ะ
โจร 2 คนจะเข้ามาปล้นบ้านน่ะแล้วก็ถูก
แกล้งเนี่ยมันก็ขำตลกตรงที่แบบโดนแกล้ง
เนี่ยแล้วคนแกล้งเป็นเด็กด้วยนะใช่มั้ย
เอออือนี้ก็จะเป็นแบบสตประเเภทหนังอีก
ประเภทนึงนะคะประเภทหนัง
ตลกมีประเภทอะไรอีกมั่ง
งหนังชีวิตหนังสงครามอ่าหนังชีวิตใช่มั้ย
หนังชีวิตเป็นไงคุูชิหนังชีวิตเนี่ยมักจะ
เอาเรื่องจริงอ่ะมาทำเป็นหนัง
อ๋อ
เหมือนเรื่องอะไรบ้างนะเอ่อ
เออหรือไม่ก็เอ่อประเทศไทยเนี่ยก็มีหนัง
วัยรุ่นน่ะที่เป็นอะไรนะเอ่อเถ้าแก่น้อย
อ่ะวัยรุ่นพันล้าน
อืนะอันนั้นก็แบบว่าเออนะเอามาทำเป็นหนัง
เพราะว่าคนจริงๆมีไงนะแล้วก็เอาชีวิตเ้า
มาสร้างเป็นหนังหรือตอนนี้หนังไทยก็มี
อะไรนะสัเห่อใช่มั้ยมีคนเนี่ยเอาเรื่องมา
เล่าให้ฟังเคก็เห็นว่าเรื่องเยน่าสนใจก็
เลยเอามาสร้างเป็นหนังหนังประเภทนี้ก็
เป็นหนังประเภทแบบเกี่ยวกับชีวิตจริงอ่า
อ่าหรือประวัติของอะไรอ่ะ
เอ่อ The
beetle นักดนตรีนักร้องใช่มยอืใช่นะสีฟ
จ๊อบเงี้ยก็เอามาสร้างเป็นหนังก็คือเอา
เอาชีวิตจริงของเค้าเนี่ยเอามาทำเป็นหนัง
นะก็เลยเรียกว่าหนังชีวิตใช่มยใช่ถูกต้อง
อันนี้ก็อันนี้ครูปุ๊กชอบมั้ยหรือเอาหนัง
ของอะไรอ่ะฮิตเลอร์อย่าเงี้ยมาสร้างเป็น
หนังไม่เอา่ะหนังสงครามครูปุ๊กก็ไม่ชอบดู
นะครูชิมีแต่ทหารแล้วก็ยิงๆๆๆๆนะเมื่อ
ก่อนมีเรื่องนึงที่แบบหลงไปดู
เนี่ยสงครามเวียดนามใช่
มั้ย Good  Morning เวียดนาม
โอ้โหรู้สึกออไม่ชอบหนังสงครามชอบหนัง
สงครามอใช่มีแต่ฆ่ากันยิงกันโอ้ไม่สนุก
ค่ะเครียดดูแล้วแบบปวดหัวงั้นก็ไปหนังที่
เกี่ยวกับ
สารคดีดูแล้วมีความ
รู้อันนั้นก็พอได้ค่ะนะเห็นม
หนังสารคดีเนี่ยเราเรานึกถึงหนังที่
เกี่ยวกับสิ่งมีินะอ่าโอฟี่เนี่ยเป็นหนัง
แบบหนังเกี่ยวกับสิ่งมีชีวิตอะไรแบบเนี้ย
นะสารคดีให้เรารู้ศึกษาให้เรารู้นะหรือไป
ทำชีวิตเกี่ยวกับอะไรอ่ะคิงคองนะกอริล่า
เราเรียกคิงคองใช่มั้ยหืออะไรนะเรื่อง
อะไรอบลก็ออหรือเป็นอะไรนะเป็นเอ่อเรื่อง
ของ
เอ่อที่ที่ที่เราเห็นมีหมูแล้วก็หมูเก่ง
อ่ะมาจากหนังสือเขียนจากหนังสือกันมามานะ
ไอ้นี่เหรอเอ่อ The  Best เป็นหนังสารคดี
มยอืเรารู้ว่าหมูเนี่ยก็เลี้ยงเลี้ยงแกะ
ได้ใช่มยปม
ย
แกะรอง
บมนะเบใช่มยหมูชื่อเบบอือหือแบบเนี้นะ
เป็นหนังประเภทนี้ได้มยเป็นหนังสารคดี
เกี่ยวกับ
ฉลามฉลามเอ่อฉลามเป็นยังไงชอบกินอะไรแบบ
นี้นะเออหรืออะไรเกี่ยวกับแมง
มุมแต่ไม่ใช่สไปเดอร์แมนนะอันนั้นเป็น
ซุปเปอร์ฮีโร่อันนั้นจะเป็นซุปเปอร์ฮีโร่
ค่ะนะใช่มตอนนี้มีหนังบูหนังผจญภัยหนัง
ตลกแล้วก็มีแอนิเมชันที่ครูปุ๊กบอกนะเอา
การ์ตูนเนี่ยมาสร้างเป็นหนังใช่มยแล้วก็
หนังชีวิตจริงหนังอาชยกรรมหนังสารคดีต้อง
อันนี้ด้วยหนังแบบคนไทยเรียกหนัง
ดราม่าดราม่ายังไงเเรียกทับศัพท์ภาษา
อังกฤษแ่ะเนาะอืคือมันก็เหมือนกับเอา
ชีวิตจริงอ่ะแต่มันแบบอันเนี้ยอาจจะแต่ง
จนรู้สึกแบบมันมันโอเวอร์ไปมากๆก็คือ
ชีวิตชีวิตมันน่าเศร้าอะไรประเภทเนี้ย
อ๋อนะดูแล้วดูแล้วก็น้ำตาไหลร้องไห้แล้ว
ร้องไห้อีกเอออือนดราม่าใช่มั้ยโใช่อัน
นี้เป็นเรื่องที่แบบน่าสงสารมากนะแต่เป็น
ซีรีส์ของญี่ใช่มั้ยอืโอชินอย่างเงี้ย
โอชินเค้าก็เกิดในในสมัยก่อนเนาะเค้าก็
แบบโอ้โหไม่มีอาหารกินต้องกินแบบขุดเอา
มันมาต้มแทนข้าวอะไรอย่างเงี้ยกินแทนข้าว
อผสมข้าวนิดหน่อยเพราะว่าข้าวเนี่ยมีน้อย
ราคาแพงนะแล้วก็โอ้โหกว่าจะโตขึ้นมากว่า
จะไปเจอสามีกว่าจะโชีวิตเนี่ยมีแต่หน่า
สงสารทั้งหมดเลยแบบโอ้โหคนเราอะไรมันจะ
ได้แบบเจอแต่สิ่งไม่ดีไม่ดีไม่ดีลำบากอ่ะ
ชีวิตลำบากเอลำบากมากอย่างงี้
อือหนังประเภทนี้เนี่ยก็บางคนก็ชอบนะบาง
คนชอบแบบหนังดราม่ามากดูแล้วก็แบบร้องไห้
ร้องไห้เสียใจแต่ก็ชอบดูเหมือนคนเหมือนคน
ที่กลัวผีแต่ชอบดูหนังหนผี
อ่ะแต่ก็มีหนังที่สไตล์แบบน่ารักๆแบบหนัง
ครอบครัวไงนะอย่างอะไรคต Kid นี่มีเป็น
หนังครอบครัวมั้ยอืมไม่แน่ใจนะหนัง
ครอบครัวอาจจะเป็นแบบครอบครัวรักกันอย่าง
งี้ไงอื
นะหรือ
ว่าหนังหนังที่แบบเอ่อพ่อเป็นนักแข่งรถ
ลูกก็เป็นนักแข่งรถแล้วก็เป็นทีมเดียวกัน
พ่อพ่อแพ้ไปลูกก็ขึ้นมาแล้วก็มาแข่ง
รถตามความรักของพ่ออะไรแบบเนี้ยเป็นหนัง
เกี่ยวกับครอบครัวเนี่ยนะเอาเรื่องน้ำหมา
แดงอ่ะ The  Big  R  Dog อ่ะฟอร์ดฟอร์ด
ใช่มั้ยเป็นหนังครอบครัว
นะหมาตัวนี้ก็เป็นหมาตัวนึงของครอบครัว
ครอบครัวนึงที่รักกันมากรักมากนะก็ดูแล
กัน
ออหรือเรื่องนึงทีู่จำได้จำชื่อเรื่องไม่
ได้ละที่ครอบครัวคุณพ่อคุณแม่แต่งงานแล้ว
มีลูกลูกอ่าคนที่ 2 ที่เป็นผู้หญิงเนี่ย
คนโตเป็นผู้ชายคนที่ 2 เป็นผู้หญิงแล้ว
เป็นโรคประจำตัวเนาะเหมือนกับเป็นมะเร็ง
ระยะสุดท้ายหรืออะไรนี่แหละแล้วแม่ก็เลย
แบบมีลูกใหม่อีกคนนึงเพื่อจะเอาเอาเซลล์
มาปลูกถ่ายให้กับพี่
นะแล้วก็ทำให้แบบก็ให้หมอทำกิ๊บนะให้ท้อง
มาเป็นลูกผู้หญิงอเพื่อจะเอาเหมือนชิ้น
ส่วนอวัยวะของน้องให้กับพี่พี่จะได้มี
ชีวิตอยู่ต่อได้นะแล้วสุดท้ายเนี่ยพี่ก็
รู้สึกว่าไม่โอเคกับน้องพี่ก็เลยให้น้อง
เนี่ยฟ้องคุณแม่ไปคอร์ดไปสานะแล้วก็ไม่
อยากบอกให้น้องบอกเหมือนไม่อยากให้ชิ้น
ส่วนตัวเองให้กับพี่อ่ะนะต้องเอาไตให้พี่
ข้างนึงนะต้องแบ่งทุกอย่างอนะเพราะว่าพี่
อาการไม่ค่อยดีพอพี่เนี่ยไปมีแฟนแล้วแฟน
ก็เป็นร็งระยะสุดท้ายด้วยนะเค้าก็เสีย
ชีวิตไปตัวเองเนี่ยทำคีโมแล้วก็ปรากฏว่า
ก็คิดว่าเอ๊ะแฟนหายไปไหนมารู้ทีหลังว่า
แฟนเสียชีวิตก็เลยเหมือนไม่ได้อยากมี
ชีวิตอยู่แล้วอ่ะนะก็เหมือนแล้วตัวเอง
อยู่เนี่ยก็น้องก็จะต้องมาเอาอวัยวะให้
ตัวเองพี่ก็เลยตัดสินใจบอกน้องเลยว่าไม่
ต้องให้ไปฟ้องแม่นะฟ้องไปแจ้งความตำรวจไป
ให้หานะอัยการไปบอกว่าไม่อยากไม่อยากเอา
ชีวิตตัวเองน่ะแบ่งให้พี่นะแล้วก็ฟ้อง
ร้องกับแม่ว่าแม่ไม่ให้แม่ทำแบบนี้อือก็
เลยเรื่องนั้นก็
เป็นครอบครัวมั้ยหรือหนัง
ชีวิตเออมันก็บางบางอย่างก็ปนๆกันนะมีมัน
มีความเป็นครอบครัวแต่มันไม่ได้แบบ
ครอบครัวอบอุ่นไงมันเป็นครอบครัวที่แบบมี
ดราม่าเข้ามานะมันอาจจะมีความเป็นดราม่า
ด้วยแล้วก็เอ่อด้วยความรักความเศ้าอ่ะมี
ความเศร้ามีครอบครัวคือความรักของแม่ไงก็
อยากไม่อยากให้ลูกเสียชีวิตไม่อยากให้ลูก
ตายแต่ว่าก็ลืมไปว่าลูกอีกคนนึงก็มีชีวิต
เหมือนกันใช่มยเาก็เลยบอกว่าเไม่อยากเกิด
มาเป็นแค่อะไหล่ของพี่อะไหล่เหมือนรถยนต์
น่ะนะล้อแม็กบ๊ายบายก็เปลี่ยนแม็กใหม่ใส่
เป็นล้ออะไหล่มาใส่อย่างเงี้ยนะแล้วก็
เหมือนต้องเอาไตเค้าเนี่ยไปให้เป็นอะไหล่
ของพี่อย่างเงี้ยก็นะชีวิตเาก็เลยเหมือน
โดนผ่าตัดโดนอะไรตั้งแต่เด็กๆเนาะเพื่อ
เอาปลูกถ่ายอวัยวะให้พี่อะไรอย่างเงี้ยนะ
แล้วจริงๆน้องก็ไม่แท่าไม่ได้อะไรแต่ว่า
พี่สาวเองเนี่ยไม่อยากไม่อยากที่จะไปเอา
ชีวิตของน้องมาให้ตัวเองไม่อยากให้น้อง
เนี่ยมีชีวิตที่เหลือแค่ครึ่งเดียวอย่าง
เงี้ยคือบางทีเนี่ยพ่อแม่ใช่มั้ยพ่อแม่
เนี่ยชอบคิดว่าฉันทำแบบเนี้ยเพราะว่ารัก
รักลูกอือนะแต่ลืมคิดว่าสิ่งที่ตัวเอง
สร้างมาก็เป็นอีกหนึ่งชีวิตที่มีชีวิต
แล้วก็มีความคิดความรู้สึกอือนะจะให้เค้า
เกิดมาเพื่อเสียสละเคยถามมั้ยว่าเค้าอยาก
จะเกิดมาแบบนี้มั้ยอยากเป็นแบบนี้มั้ยอื
นะนะอันนนี้ก็น่าสงสารเนาะอืมคือก็เข้าใจ
ความคิดของแม่แต่ก็ในมุมของลูกคนที่เกิด
มาเนี่ยนะเค้าทำคือตั้งใจให้เค้าเกิดมา
เป็นอะไหลจริงๆไงมันก็เลยกลายเป็นว่าเด็ก
คนเนี้ยก็จะไม่เหมือนจะไม่ได้รับความรัก
จากแม่มากเท่ากับพี่อย่างเงี้ยเาะน้องก็
อาจจะรู้สึกแบบนั้นไงนะอืแต่แม่คิดว่าเออ
2 คนก็มีชีวิตอยู่ได้ใช่มยแต่ก็อาจจะ
อยู่ได้กันคนละครึ่งอย่างเงี้ยอืเขไม่
อยากให้ลูก
ตายหรือประเภทหนังแฟนตาซีล่ะแฟนตาซีก็
โอเคค่ะเนาะเป็นหนังที่บางทีเนี่ยสร้างมา
มันก็กึ่งคล้ายๆแบบวิทยาศาสตร์เหมือนกัน
นะแล้วก็เป็นแบบแฟนตาซีคือสร้างมาแบบ
อย่างอย่างอะไร the  mon  the  the  monst
นะคะดูหมาก็ดูน่ากลัวแบบสร้างมาแล้วก็น่า
จะใช้
เอ่อวิธีการสร้างภาพที่มันทำให้เรารู้สึก
ว่าโอ้โหแฟนตาซีมาก
อมีอะไรพิเศษขึ้นมาอที่เราแบบไม่เห็นในใน
ชีวิตจริงแน่ๆไม่ได้เห็นในชีวิตทั่วๆไปคน
บินได้คนเหาะได้นะคะอย่างอะไรอ่ะ He
never  die เนี่ยมีคนมีปีกเงี้ยออันนี้
ก็เป็นประเภทหนังนะจริงๆมีประเภทหนังเยอะ
นะสำหรับเอ่อให้นักเรียนรู้จักนะคะหนัง
สงครามหนังสยองขวัญวิทยาศาสตร์อาชญกรรม
ระทึกขวัญอะไรแบบเนี้ยนะคะก็วนวนดูอีกรอบ
แล้วกันนะคะเพื่อทบทวนว่าประเภทหนังต่างๆ
เนี่ยเรียกว่าอะไรบ้างนะคะวันนี้หมดเวลา
แล้วค่ะครูปุ๊กค่ะเราก็ต้องลาทุกคนไปก่อน
นะคะแล้วก็เรามาเจอกันในคลิปต่อๆไปแล้ว
กันนะคะขอบคุณค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะครู
ปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน